[Music]
gina is with us in tulsa oklahoma to
start off this hour hi gina how are you
i'm good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so i am actually being sued by a payday
lender and i would like to know how to
go about dealing with this
wow
life must be rough
yes a little bit
i mean number one you went into a payday
lender and then number two you didn't
pay them and then number three you
didn't pay them for so long that they
sued you you've been struggling a while
yes it was in 2016
and yes i should have paid and i can't
remember exactly why i didn't pay at
this point but yes now they've
contacted me and are trying to sue me
and they're going to win
they're going to win
how much is it for gina
so the actual loan i took out was for
400 and then it was going to be like 600
um to pay back but now they're saying
that i owe like uh 2500 for like court
costs or things like that well in five
or six years worth of interest
yeah because you haven't dealt with this
how old are you
i am 31.
how many other things in your life have
been unkept for this long
um there's that payday loan and um
i think i have some student loan debt as
well
you don't think you know
yes i know okay
and if you did anything about it or is
it just sitting there since 2016.
um
before the pandemic i had reached out to
them to try to set up payments and then
because of the pandemic and all that
i haven't made any payments
when did you graduate
um so actually i didn't end up
graduating i went to dental assisting
school back in like 2010.
okay what do you make now
um
what do you mean what i'm making what is
your income
like
30 000 a year
what do you do
i'm a cna currently
do you have any money
yes how much
i probably got about four grand in the
bank good
call the attorney that's suing
and tell them
that you're broke and you can't pay them
twenty five hundred dollars but you'd be
happy to pay them to six hundred or even
a thousand to settle this
because it's such an old debt
and begin to negotiate and argue with
and you will find the person on the
other end of the phone to be a complete
twerp
but that's just part of the process
this is not this is going to be
unpleasant but it's going to be less
unpleasant than losing a lawsuit and
having them garnish your wages
yes and i've already i tried contacting
them via email and they wanted uh like
my copy of my paper
nope nope nope they get no information
i'll give you a thousand dollars cash
settlement in full
i'm not giving you squat
kiss my butt
this is how the negotiation sounds
okay
no you can't have anything you but you
need to get on the phone with them
okay so it's better to call not email
yeah yeah and just argue with them and
if you get any
if they are going to settle you need
that in writing before you send them
money and then when you do come to
agreement and they go okay we'll do
eleven hundred dollars or whatever it is
you end up like nine hundred dollars
whatever it is you end up agreeing for
okay
then say i need that in an email in
writing and i will immediately wire you
the money
so two rules here
number three rules for you number one
deal with this
yes you've been sticking your head in
the sand long enough deal with it
because it's not gonna get anything but
worse same thing with student loans deal
with it
number two
get it in writing
okay
it didn't happen if it's not in writing
it's a lie
they lie
okay okay
and they don't mind lying to you because
they consider you a liar since 2016.
okay so get it in writing number three
no electronic access to your checking
account under any circumstances
they're going to say oh just give us
your account number and we'll clean out
your account is what they're going to do
then you want the money for rent
okay so no i will wire you the money
or i can send you a prepaid debit card
with that amount on it
or something like that but no electronic
access to your checking account and no
personal information
do not give them any more information
they have a phone number on you and you
can block that if you need to
but don't tell them where you live don't
tell them
anything because they're going to use
all of that as leverage to garnish your
butt if you don't get this settled
okay
and but deal with this
jaina there's a pattern with you
and you've got to break that pattern
okay
for your own good for your own good
this stuff does not get better by by
ignoring it do you understand and do you
agree
yes i understand and i agree good okay
because uh you you get these things
behind you you got a bright wonderful
future
but not dealing with things since 2016
is um it's a problem
and then you use language like i think i
have a snow you know you have a student
loan this all indicates where your head
space is on this it's that and the the
proactiveness gina which obviously we
can't do for you or change your heart in
this or your energy behind it
um but when i hear people you know use
that language even it's like she knows
it's there she probably doesn't know
really how much specifically no yeah the
interest that's occurred when does it
like like it's it's just it's kind of
all over the place and denial is not
just a river in egypt though i mean
that's really it's it's not it's it's
something that it's something that
people actually do
and so
so yeah how do you spell that you've
gotta you have to you have to push this
through okay
and so the number one habit of highly
effective people in stephen covey's book
the seven habits of highly effective
people is they're proactive they happen
two things things don't happen to them
when you have a situation where there is
conflict and you do not get closure on
it whether it's financial conflict legal
conflict whether it's relational
conflict whatever it is and you don't
get closure on it it does not get better
it gets worse
100 of the time
it gets worse until there's closure
it just continues to grow and grow and
grow and grow and get worse and worse
and worse and worse it's a problem so
there you go